>>> THIS MORNING, THERE IS NEW
DATA ON THE EFFECTIVENESS OF
VACCINES SPECIFICALLY AGAINST
THE OMICRON VARIANT.
A NEW STUDY FROM SOUTH AFRICA
SUGGESTS THAT TWO DOSES OF THE
PFIZER VACCINE ARE ONLY ABOUT
33% EFFECTIVE AGAINST THE
VARIANT.
REMEMBER, THE SAME VACCINE THAT
WAS MORE THAN 90% EFFECTIVE
AGAINST THE ORIGINAL COVID
STRAIN WHICH VACCINES WERE
RELEASED, WE SHOULD NOTE EXACTLY
ONE YEAR AGO TODAY.
ON THE POSITIVE SIDE, THAT SAME
STUDY FOUND VACCINATED PEOPLE
WHO ARE INFECTED WITH OMICRON
ARE ABOUT ONE-THIRD LESS LIKELY
TO END UP IN THE HOSPITAL WHEN
COMPARED TO THE ORIGINAL STRAIN
OF THE VIRUS.
JOINING ME NOW TO DISCUSS THIS
AND MANY ISSUES, DR. ANTHONY
FAUCI, DIRECTOR OF THE NATIONAL
INSTITUTE OF ALLERGY AND
INFECTIOUS DISEASES.
GOOD TO HAVE YOU BACK ON THE
PROGRAM.
>> THANK YOU, JIM.
GOOD TO BE WITH YOU.
>> SO, FIRST, LAST WEEK YOU WERE
ON CNN AND YOU SAID THAT THE NIH
LAB WAS EXPECTING TO HAVE
RESULTS EARLY NEXT WEEK, THAT IS
THIS WEEK ON VACCINE EFFICACY
AGAINST OMICRON.
IS THERE NEW DATA AND WHAT DOES
IT SHOW?
>> WELL, YOU KNOW, WE'RE GOING
TO BE TALKING ABOUT IT TOMORROW.
BUT IT IS MOSTLY CONFIRMS WHAT
YOU HAVE BEEN HEARING THAT HAVE
COME FROM SOUTH AFRICA AS WELL
AS THE UK.
THE DATA YOU SHOWED UP ON THE
SCREEN, JIM, IS CORRECT.
WHAT HAPPENS IS THAT IF YOU GET
TWO DOSES OF A PFIZER OR A
MODERNA, THE PROTECTION AGAINST
INFECTION ITSELF IS DRAMATICALLY
DOWN.
HOWEVER, WHAT IS THE SOMEWHAT
ENCOURAGING NEWS IS THAT THE
PROTECTION AGAINST
HOSPITALIZATION AND SEVERE
DISEASE, ALTHOUGH IT GOES DOWN
TO AROUND 70% FROM AROUND 93%,
WHEN YOU GET BOOSTED, IT BRINGS
IT BACK UP TO THE LEVEL OF
PRETTY GOOD PROTECTION, WHICH IS
A VERY STRONG ARGUMENT FOR
PEOPLE GETTING THEIR BOOSTERS.
SO OMICRON IS GOING TO BE A
CHALLENGE BECAUSE IT SPREADS
VERY RAPIDLY AND THE VACCINES
THAT WE USE, THE REGULAR
TWO-DOSE MRNA, DON'T DO VERY
WELL AGAINST INFECTION ITSELF.
BUT PARTICULARLY IF YOU GET THE
BOOST, IT IS PRETTY GOOD.
>> SHOULD WE THEN BE LOOKING AT
THIS REALLY AS A THREE-SHOT
VACCINE WHEN IT COMES TO PFIZER?
THAT THAT BOOST IS NOT JUST AN
ADVANTAGE, BUT MIGHT BE A
REQUIREMENT?
>> WELL, AGAIN, THERE IS A
DIFFERENCE THERE, JIM.
IT IS A SENSITIVE ISSUE BECAUSE
OF THE LEGAL ISSUES ABOUT WHAT
IS GOING TO BE A REQUIREMENT
THAT IS NOW UNDER LITIGATION.
THE SITUATION IS THERE IS NO
DOUBT WE CAN SAY THAT OPTIMAL
PROTECTION WHEN YOU DEAL WITH AN
MRNA IS WITH THREE DOSES.
THERE IS NO DOUBT ABOUT THAT.
BOTH FOR THE DURABILITY OF THE
PROTECTION AND AS WELL AS THE
PROTECTION AGAINST THE OMICRON
VARIANT.
SO THERE IS LITTLE DOUBT ABOUT
THAT AMONG THOSE OF US WHO WORK
IN THIS FIELD.
>> WE ARE SEEING, THOUGH, AN
ORGANIZATION LIKE THE NFL
BASICALLY MOVE FORWARD TO NOW
REQUIRE THAT THIRD SHOT.
THE THING IS MANY COMPANIES,
PRIVATE COMPANIES AS WELL AS
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AGENCIES,
THEY LOOK TO THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT.
SHOULD THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT BE
LEADING ON THIS IN TERMS OF
REQUIRING BOOSTERS?
>> WELL, AGAIN, THERE IS A
DIFFERENCE, IT IS A SUBTLE
DIFFERENCE, JIM, BETWEEN
REQUIREMENT AND OPTIMAL.
I CAN TELL ANY ORGANIZATION THAT
ASKS ME WHAT IS THE OPTIMAL TO
PROTECT OURSELFS?
BE IT YOUR ATHLETES OR BE IT THE
PEOPLE IN -- THERE IS NO DOUBT
THAT THE OPTIMAL PROTECTION IS
GOING TO BE WITH THREE DOSES OF
AN MRNA.
>> UNDERSTOOD.
OKAY.
LET'S MOVE ON TO ANOTHER
TREATMENT, WHICH IS SHOWING
PROGRESS AND PROMISE AND THAT IS
COVID PILL.
THIS MORNING, PFIZER RELEASED
UPDATED RESULTS FOR ITS COVID-19
PILL.
IT SHOWS CUT THE RISK OF
HOSPITALIZATION OR DEATH BY 89%
WHEN GIVEN TO HIGH RISK ADULTS,
THOUGH, WITHIN A FEW DAYS OF THE
FIRST SYMPTOMS.
I DON'T WANT TO SUGGEST THIS IS
A SUBSTITUTE FOR VACCINES,
YOU'VE BEEN CLEAR ABOUT THAT,
FOLKS SHOULD GET VACCINATED.
BUT FOR THE FOLKS WHO ARE NOT
GETTING VACCINATED.
ABOUT A QUARTER OF THE COUNTRY
AT THIS POINT.
FOR THOSE PEOPLE IS THIS PILL
POTENTIALLY A LIFE SAVER?
>> WELL, THE PILL IS POTENTIALLY
A LIFE SAVER FOR EVERYONE, JIM,
VACCINATED AND UNVACCINATED
PEOPLE.
EVEN VACCINATED PEOPLE WHO ARE
IN A HIGHER RISK GROUP, THE
ELDERLY, THOSE WITH UNDERLYING
CONDITIONS, CAN HAVE SERIOUS
DISEASE LEADING TO
HOSPITALIZATION.
THE GOOD NEWS ABOUT THIS
MORNING, I WAS ON THE PHONE WITH
THE CHIEF -- THE SCIENTIFIC
OFFICER OF THE COMPANY, JUST
LITERALLY A COUPLE OF HOURS AGO,
THE GOOD NEWS ABOUT THAT IS THAT
THE PRELIMINARY DATA SHOWED
ABOUT AN 89% PROTECTION FROM
HOSPITALIZATION OR DEATH HAVE
GIVEN WITHIN THE FIRST THREE
DAYS OF SYMPTOMS.
NOW THAT THE COMPLETE FULL FINAL
DATA CENTER IS IN IS JUST AS
GOOD IF NOT BETTER.
THAT'S REALLY GOOD NEWS.
IT IS HOLDING OFF UNDER LARGER
NUMBERS OF PEOPLE.
THEY'RE GOING TO BE SUBMITTING
THAT TO THE FDA AND HOPEFULLY
WE'LL GET ACTION ON THAT SOON.
>> IT IS HAS BEEN A YEAR TO THE
DAY SINCE VACCINES FIRST CAME
OUT.
BUT IT IS ALSO WELL MORE THAN A
YEAR INTO THIS PANDEMIC.
AND WE WERE LOOKING AT THE DEATH
TOLL AND THE FIRST NINE MONTHS
OF THE PANDEMIC FROM FEBRUARY --
FROM THE FIRST DEATH ON FEBRUARY
29th, 2020, TO NINE MONTHS
LATER, 269,000 DEATHS, A LITTLE
BIT MORE.
IN THE LAST NINE MONTHS, VERY
CLOSE TO THAT, 255,000.
AND THOSE ARE NINE MONTHS IN
WHICH THE VACCINE, HIGHLY
EFFECTIVE VACCINE HAS BEEN
AVAILABLE AND FREE AND
DISTRIBUTED AROUND THE COUNTRY.
WHY HASN'T IT GOTTEN ANY BETTER
IN TERMS OF THE OVERALL DEATH
TOLL AND DOES IT SURPRISE YOU?
>> WELL, IT DOESN'T BECAUSE
THERE ARE TWO THINGS THAT ARE
CONVERGING HERE, JIM.
ONE IS WE'RE DEALING WITH DELTA.
WE DIDN'T HAVE DELTA A YEAR AGO.
WE'RE DEALING WITH A MUCH MORE
FORMIDABLE VIRUS IN EVERY
RESPECT.
SUPER IMPOSED UPON THAT, IF WE
HAD OPTIMALLY IMPLEMENTED A
VACCINE PROGRAM, THOSE NUMBERS
WOULD HAVE BEEN DOWN.
THOSE ARE -- MANY OF THEM, NOT
ALL OF THEM, MANY OF THEM ARE
UNNECESSARY DEATHS BECAUSE WE
HAVE UP TO 60 MILLION PEOPLE IN
THIS COUNTRY WHO ARE ELIGIBLE TO
BE VACCINATED WHO HAVE NOT
GOTTEN VACCINATED.
WE HAVE GOT TO BE DOING BETTER
THAN THAT IF WE WANT TO GET THIS
THING OVER WITH.
>> DR. PAUL OFFIT, ON THE FDA
ADVISER COMMITTEE, HE WAS ON THE
SHOW LAST WEEK.
AND HE MADE A POINT WHICH IS --
HE'S NOT ALONE IN THIS THERE IS
A POSSIBILITY THAT OMICRON TAKES
OVER DELTA IN THIS COUNTRY, MORE
TRANSMISSIBLE, BUT CAUSING LESS
SEVERE ILLNESS.
AND I KNOW IT IS EARLY IN THIS,
SO WE DON'T WANT TO GET AHEAD OF
WHERE THE DATA IS.
BUT IS THAT A POSSIBLE OUTCOME
HERE, THAT OMICRON BECOMES
DOMINANT, BUT THERE IS AN
ADVANTAGE IN THAT IT IS LESS
DANGEROUS?
>> THAT IS A POSSIBILITY.
BUT LET ME GIVE YOU THE DETAILS
ABOUT WHERE WE GET THOSE DATA.
MOSTLY FROM SOUTH AFRICA.
SO IN SOUTH AFRICA THEY'RE
GETTING A VERY, VERY PRONOUNCED
SPREAD, ALMOST A VERTICAL SPIKE
OF INFECTION.
AND YET WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE
EARLY DATA, IT DOES APPEAR THAT
THERE IS A DIMINUTION IN THE
SEVERITY AS EXPRESSED BY
HOSPITALIZATION.
THE REAL QUESTION IS, IS THAT AN
INHERENT DIMINUTION OF VIRULENCE
OF THE VIRUS OR IS IT BECAUSE
THERE ARE SO MANY PEOPLE IN THE
POPULATION WHO HAVE ALREADY BEEN
INFECTED AND NOW HAVE RESIDUAL
POST INFECTION IMMUNITY, WHICH
IS NOT PROTECTING THEM FROM
GETTING INFECTED, BUT IS
PROTECTING THEM FROM GETTING
SEVERE DISEASE.
WHATEVER IT IS, THE DISEASE
SEEMS TO BE LESS SEVERE.
WHETHER IT IS INHERENTLY LESS
PATHOGENIC AS A VIRUS OR WHETHER
THERE IS MORE PROTECTION IN THE
COMMUNITY.
WE'RE JUST GOING TO HAVE TO SEE
WHEN IT COMES IN THE UNITED
STATES.
AND FOR SURE, JIM, IT IS GOING
TO BE DOMINANT IN THE UNITED
STATES, GIVEN